who among dc comics long list of
do-gooders
near due wells and everyone in between
most deserve their own shot at cinematic
greatness
that's what we're here to answer keep
watching to find out which dc characters
deserve their own movie
life in gotham city is tough for
everyone sure
you'll get to see the bad signals
splashed across the clouds every once in
a while but is that worth the headache
of the batmobile tying up downtown
traffic
now imagine being a gotham city police
department detective
that's the plight of renee montoya
created for batman the animated series
she came into her own within the pages
of the gotham central story arc
half a life in which she's outed as a
lesbian her life is never smooth
from her romantic entanglement to her
disillusionment with the system she
works within
one of her most notable exploits is
assuming the mantle of the question
a faceless hero who does the work that
an officer of the loa cannot
her deep-seated devotion to making the
world a better place
always endures in spite of brutal
memories regrets and too many bottles of
liquor
she's exactly the sort of complex
character that dc movies deserve
the martian manhunter is a bit of a
collage as far as superheroes go
sometimes his backstory indicates that
he comes from a populist mars full of
sentient life
while other versions cast him as the
last of his race his name implies a
ferocity that doesn't define him
though he's had multiple solo titles to
his name he's probably best known as a
member of the justice league he's also
an obsessive fan of a certain brand of
chocolate sandwich cookie
this is all to say that he contains
multitudes and that's exactly why he
deserves his own movie
just picture it alone on a strange
planet martian manhunter attempts to
blend in with the local populace
but with subpar results 2019 shazam
demonstrated just how much fun dc movies
can be while telling a fish out of water
story
so why not take it to an interplanetary
scale while billy batson was a kid
confronted with adult responsibilities
manhunter is a poised adult marooned in
a world that he doesn't understand
but still wants to save he's a calm
meditative presence sure but he also
doesn't realize how hilarious he looks
in a gaudy christmas sweater
i wasn't sure about the size
i can grow into it he's a hero who's as
inspiring as he is endearing
with shape-shifting powers that could
launch a film into the stratosphere of
visual heights
what's not to love the early 2000s teen
titans cartoon had a lot going for it
and one of its greatest assets was the
serially serious secretly sympathetic
raven
voiced to gravely perfection by tara
strong raven was the sarcastic heart of
the show
it's this contrast that makes her so
beloved in all of her incarnations
though she keeps to herself and can be
quick with a barb she loves with a
passion so fierce it can overturn the
apocalypse
a movie starring raven would have a
multitude of story possibilities
it could be set in high school with the
character's dark origin serving as a
potent metaphor for adolescence
another option would be to go in a
horror direction by drawing upon the
eldritch nature of raven's heritage
still more choices could include a
fantasy tale set in her home realm of
azerath
or a team story set in titans tower what
makes all these possibilities so potent
is the presence of a young woman aching
to do some good in the world
despite daunting challenges as long as
that element is there
everything else will fall into place
azerathmetrion
everyone loves magic tricks sure some of
us like to call out the moment that the
illusion falls apart
and when we grow up we're not so easily
fooled anymore
but there's a reason that sleight of
hand tricks remain eternally popular
there's just something undeniably
exciting about seeing the laws of
reality
seemingly being broken zetana zatara
channels that thrill
in high style while also adding some
literal magic
rather than receding into the shadows of
a secret identity
she embraces her powers by becoming an
internationally renowned illusionist who
chases down the bad guys when she's not
taking curtain calls
this charisma makes her a charming
character no matter what the setting or
creative team
she's got all the swagger of a showman
plus the do-gooding heart of a hero
additionally the sheer scope of her
abilities allows for enormous flights of
visual and storytelling fancy
her powers might occasionally take the
wind out of her but they will also make
for some smashing cinema
most superheroes are notable for their
daring deeds heroic creeds or striking
aesthetics
and then there's booster gold it's not
like booster hasn't saved the world
or continuously strive to do the right
thing or work with other heroes and
thrilling tributes to the power of
teamwork
the trouble is though he messes up a lot
also he originally became a superhero to
build a corporate empire
and furthermore his powers mostly come
from things that he stole
booster was once a denizen of gotham
city during the 25th century
laid low by his gambling attic father
schemes he ended up stealing super
heroic tech from the metropolis space
museum
getting a robotic security guard named
skeets on his side and jumping into the
past to make a name for himself
this was all entirely off the wonder and
magic of
other better heroes and it mostly blew
up in booster's face
when the public wasn't mangling his name
into buster he was going bankrupt
and yet he persevered he's been a repo
man with his super heroic bestie blue
beetle and he's also saved the world
alongside the justice league
while he's made his share of mistakes
he's always moved forward
ultimately he's perfectly suited to lead
one of the most
moving superhero films ever his origin
and grifting defines him
not in terms of its success but in how
far he's moved beyond it
oh hey guys i was just
totally meditating there about stopping
crime and stuff
batman and robin might be a legendary
dynamic duo
but the person in the green pixie boots
hasn't always been the same boy wonder
there was dick grayson the original
sidekick who's now known as nightwing
then there was jason todd who was
infamously killed off by a phone and
vote
next came tim drake whiz kid child of
the 90s
even a few young women have been robbing
but only one robin has
ever been bruce wayne's actual son the
harassable
irresistible damian wayne the product of
bruce's romance with the deadly taliyah
ghoul damian was trained by the league
of assassins in every way to kill a man
unfortunately he didn't also receive any
instruction in basic human empathy
so he arrived at wayne manor a
self-important prickly wonderkind
with a chip on his shoulder the size of
the batmobile and yet despite
all his arrogance he proves to be a
young man longing for his father though
he would rather die than admit it
after years of kindness hard work and
getting used to his dad's no kill policy
damian has emerged as one of dc's most
compelling heroes
thus making him a prime candidate to
lead his own movie
and after all who wouldn't want to see
batman in a parent teacher conference on
the big screen
speedy is perhaps best known for his
struggles with drug addiction which have
become a bit of a joke among many dc
fans he was immortalized on the cover of
1971's green lantern green arrow number
85
in which he's caught using heroin while
green arrow exclaims in
absolute horror my ward is a junkie
that cover launched a storyline that
follows the character to this day
speedy who went on to re-christen
himself arsenal and red arrow
continues to struggle with demons and
when you factor in leon
his daughter of the villainous cheshire
his complications
only get more complicated but despite
all of this
he keeps on persisting has he fallen off
the wagon
yes has he always made the best choices
no
but he nevertheless refuses to stop
believing in his own ability to change
for the better that's the kind of super
heroic moral
big enough for the silver screen with a
name like deathstroke the terminator
you can tell he won't be a subtle
character so the writers changed his
name to simply deathstroke
see much more subtle with his long
history of cruelty
betrayal manipulation and of course
termination
he's definitely lived up to his
over-the-top moniker
despite all of that some of the best
creators in comics have still managed to
make him a fascinating symbol of
hardcore comics
xs perhaps his most widely known
incarnation is the animated version as
ron perlman's silky portrayal of him in
the 2003 teen titans cartoon is
unforgettably chilling
hurry your time is running out
the comics have followed suit with works
like christopher priest's deathstroke
series
exploring the man in the mass as a
soldier who can't quit the fight
despite the way it ensnares his family
and friends though he never quite earns
redemption
he does find a place as the man who does
what others won't
while undeniably doing it in style he
brings the violence a plenty
but he accompanies it with pathos and an
exploration of what violence does to a
man's life
would he become a good guy by the end of
a movie about him probably not
but he could confront the audience with
a vision of the superhero game's eternal
enemies and that would make for a unique
film indeed
but just make sure you don't confuse him
with a similarly named marvel character
i'm not deadpool i thought deadpool was
a good guy why does everybody think of
deadpool
you got them guns and the swords yeah
well lots of people have guns
and swords okay superhero movies are
going cosmic
thanks to the likes of the guardians of
the galaxy captain marvel and shazam
those films much like the comics they're
based on are weird
wild and wide in scope dc has an
incredible history of telling these
kinds of stories which is abundantly
clear
in the case of big barter she comes from
apocalypse an industrial hellscape ruled
by fear
degradation and violence raised to be
one of the female furies
a terrifyingly vicious pack of warrior
women who do the bidding of apocalypse
rule of dark side
she finds salvation in the form of
scot-free who will become the heroic mr
miracle
it is alongside scott that barter finds
strength and freedom
finally allowing her to escape
apocalypse and find a life worth living
on earth
her tale is a classic one in which a
hero discovers that she's far
stronger than she'd realize and how much
she can change her own life
plus she's a heavy hitter for the ages
and wears unquestionably one of the
coolest costumes of all time
she's a hero who never thought she'd be
one she's not just a potential big
screen star
she's already ready for her close-up
once upon a time an alien baby
crash-landed in the rural united states
adopted by kindly humans as a beloved
son he was perfectly normal in
appearance
yet he possessed incredible powers like
flight invulnerability
and super strength he would go on to
protect the world with these fabulous
gifts as he sought to make society a
better
safer and more just placed of course
we're talking about the one and only
icon while superman ended up in kansas
icon crashed in the fields of the
antebellum south where an enslaved woman
named miriam took him in
for decades he bided his time using his
powers to perform
small acts of good waiting for earth's
technology to catch up with that of his
alien home
but he couldn't lie low forever after
the teenage raquel irvin witnessed his
powers
she persuaded him to become a superhero
and make her his sidekick as she became
the irrepressible rocket
together they work to make the world a
better place
icon isn't just a hero he's a testament
to the power of kindness toward all
grace under pressure and the bonds of
service that can unite generations
he's not just a hero anyone can love
he's someone the moviegoing public needs
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loopa videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one